assez incroyable c'est le résultat de
beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup de
difficultés durant la saison
au final c'est travail de tout un goût
oui c'est vrai c'est vachement fait le
boulot de deux mecs dont adorable c'est
un très bon gars sont forts que les
enfants mais en compte et on peut
compter sur lui
[Rires]
[Musique]
le
gamin il s'est fait tout seul à cette
époque là il faisait 30 kilos tout
mouillé 1 m 40 et qu'il se battait avec
des garçons qui faisait deux fois qu'ils
remplissent deux fois plus fort que lui
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal de 2 sec 31/100 de
formation quand j'étais jeune
le fait d'être un amateur sam en soit
c'est sûr ça m'a construit en tant que
footballeur en tant qu'homme
[Musique]
à
on attend de voir ce qui va donner en
idées
[Musique]
j'en ai entendu parler mes coéquipiers
m'ont fait passer quelques-uns ouais
c'est juste des choses pour l'espagne
pour rigoler un peu me fais pas trop
attention à cela
on est tous on va dire bluffé par son
par son talent c'est un joueur qui joue
simple qui joue juste et c'est un très
bon gars ont déjà vu se lâcher sourire
même triché au jeu de cartes
c'est qu'il me regarde donc je veux dire
[Musique]
ado et naulleau côté à droite et au
centre
glauque raté
[Musique]
on
ngolo up du match sur la demi finale
aller homme du match la demi finale
retour
homme du match de la finale vous êtes en
armes
en gros ça c'est secondaire le principal
c'est ce qu'on a fait on s'est battu
pour se qualifier en finale et la
dictaure aujourd'hui on a souffert on
s'est battu jusqu'à la fin et on a la
réponse
la récompense de la victoire hendry
d'habitude je vous connais bien vous
êtes timide vous faites des réponses
assez courte vous n'avez pas forcément
le sourire est là c'est un autre ngolo
concours d'ego c'est toujours le même
mais c'est juste de la joie leur état de
beaucoup d'efforts de travail du tout
d'un groupe et on savoure c'est tout
[Musique]
on est français et on est fier de vous
avoir en équipe